hi there steve kaufman here uh you can
see that i'm back in vancouver
you can even hear my wife practicing her
piano in the background
we came back from palm springs yesterday
of course it's raining today in
vancouver
i put up a video in polish
i just wanted to get you know the 90-day
child my wife walked away from the piano
um
you know just the sort of final uh
video on on polish i will continue to
you know read and listen to polish
but the 90-day period of intensive study
is over it was a wonderful experience i
learned so much about poland
i now feel that i understand the
language i can understand podcasts so
much better i can read the newspaper
um
and i don't know what my next challenge
will be i've got so many languages that
i would like to improve in
and yet uh
the challenge of taking on something
like arabic or turkish really sort of
catches my fancy so we'll see what
happens
um
you'll notice in my video uh in polish
that i struggle with some words like for
meat and pork and beef
because these are words that have not
come up in my um listening and reading i
mean you can only learn the words that
are relevant to whatever your you know
needs are so
uh if i were visiting and going to
restaurants or buying food in poland i
would learn the words for food
uh some people think that some words are
naturally more important or higher in
the pecking order than others and you
should learn those first
but i think it all matters it all
depends on what you are interested in
you need the words that you need for the
subject matter that you are listening to
and reading so your interest will
dictate which words you learn
rather than some arbitrary list in my
view
again my language learning is driven by
my interests
one
further thing i would like to mention is
that my wife and i are going to be
traveling to europe we're going to visit
our my son and his family who live in
london
we are going to fly to paris
we're taking the train to lyon and we're
going to spend three days in lyon from
the 11th so we're leaving here the 10th
we arrive in paris on the 11th 11th 12th
13th and 14th we're in lyon
15th we fly to bristol and then we're
going to spend three days in wales and
three days in bath we're going to visit
and get to know parts of england then
from about the 22nd on we're in london
until about the 2nd of january then
we're going to spend about four days in
paris from the 3rd to the 7th including
a side trip to love where we have some
very good friends
so if there is any interest in a meet-up
either in lyon
or in
somewhere in wales
or
you know bath bristol or whatever
um
and then in london
and then in paris
please let me know and i will put the
dates here in the description
and you should get the um
the transcript for this a video within a
day or two but i'm just putting it up
right behind my
polish video
uh just to explain that the video the
conversation that i had with
carolina was initially about food
and i definitely struggled
to express myself about what canadians
like to eat so thanks for listening
and i look forward hopefully to meeting
some of you during my trip to europe bye
for now